semaine c'est la semaine de la presse à
l'école aujourd'hui avec le lycée
mathias de chalon sur saône
après les loups on découvre ce que nous
ont réservé les garçons avec une
chronique qui concerne paraît-il tous
les jeunes c'est vous qui nous l'avait
vendu comme ça donc attention grosse
pression allait l'autre et elle est ce
que vous savez ce qui se passe le 15
juin monsieur train est annoncé alors si
le 18 mai sionisme est ce que 18 joueurs
le 18 juin je vais dire non à l'eva
blessure et c'est toujours vous
apportant notre vie depuis connexion
nous en parle a tenté le coup maintenant
bien rodée plutôt punchy depuis l'époque
du bac à sable
j'avais même pas dire écrire comment
parler des jeux c'est le métayer un
brouhaha
pour moi c'était arrêté en même temps où
c'était hier c'est c'est le fameux bac
et cette année c'est le bac mairie a le
bac reste the buck consécration
ça s'est passé cette année là et c'est
parce que gray blanc c'est pas grave
hein pas là bas avec le bas qui
s'enrichit le bac on peut tout avoir
l'ajustement par exemple pas vers moi
m'a dit que si j'ai le bac et ben may
chez trash va être musicien body match
là et c'est vrai que les nouvelles se
demande si vous avez présenté dans une
grande salle pour ce remake des
chevaliers du fiel mais mon un très gros
problème monsieur parce que on est là
c'est cette année on a le bac mais toute
la société contre nous genre par exemple
par exemple nous les samedis matins
quand on se réveille on est déterminés
on veut on se ment produits sont pour
attaquer le bac on se dit qu'on va
réviser toute la journée
et là on voit quoi on voit la console
les jeux vidéo mais également des écrans
et là on la voit à 10h11 ion à faire
qu'une partie ont une partie on commença
on commence à 10h en communiquer les
résultats des comptes on est fatigué on
est blasé il y en a perdu notre temps on
a perdu notre temps et c'est comme une
drogue
pourquoi c'est une drogue va pousser une
drogue parce que ça nous rend dépendant
on joue toute la journée on sait pas
pourquoi on veut pas s'arrêter
on peut s'apprendre on est fatigué on
est fatigué a rien faire on a six mains
table oui après un certain type de
joueurs quand ils jouent andrée qui
jouent leur vie ils sont là ils sont
excités quand ils perdent et
sensu qui sont stressés après à d'autres
types de joueurs qu'ils sont omnibulé
par l'écran ils sont là ils ils sont
crispés ils sont nés six et ils jouent
la bouge
et voilà ça pour quoi faire et c'est
leur vie s'énerve et en plus on ne dit
pas que c'est une drogue on joue toute
sa journée mais ma mère c'est elle qui
m'a acheté la console elle elle m'a pas
dit que c'était une drogue
enfin alors ça qui est bizarre alors
comment mon père mois si me voir pendant
9 mai une drogue tout la cigarette by me
casses les gens mois alors que halak
alors qu'elle veut rien dire ma mère si
certains acheter leurs conseils et
qu'est-ce que vous conseiller
sincèrement en main aux jeunes qui
sortent avec nous là si on a qui restent
encore la fin prévue au contrat l'aide
pour les conseils de faire un peu de
philo c'est tout l'art nouveau
attention parce que ils ou elles coûtent
1 parce qu'elle nous a fait quelque
chose je suis que tout à l'heure qui
concerne notre prof en éclats moi je
pense qu'il faut arrêter tout il ne faut
pas succomber à ses désirs ou là il faut
ranger sa console dans un placard pour
cette année je pense à son excuse moi
dit elle mais non bah on peut pas
renoncer à ses désirs parce qu'on est
tous humains déjà donc moi je pense qu'
il faudrait au contraire ne pas renoncer
à ses désirs mais savoir mettre des
limites à ses désirs c'est très bien et
prochain spectacle comment alors remis
la libye sans sympa il serait lille où
on leur donne une note savvas comme un
moyen aller 7
cette disposition sur 10